welcome to this video estrela del mar
new opponent but I know who does this
tee bit of money so let's see what what
happens here it's mostly playing if for
I know that what I'm going to do maybe
try try the Carol powerful check
probably he will play Bishop g5 why I
play this funky 94 line I think I I told
him that that I play this line and I
must admit that by now i have very
reliably forgotten how it is played I
think greenie for is the move okay just
retreating what is right here before is
still hanging though do I do it kappa
with Bishop f5 or do I play ecigs yeah
u6 Queenie for it's not clear what is
really doing
okay i'm going to guarantee cover this
first he has some development issues
92-93 check is not great it cannot move
the night and I prepare he 6 of course I
want to get my pieces out eventually f6
is very ugly but it keeps the light only
five this is something maybe you should
castle long here going to play e6 in any
case yeah this is preparing to develop
probably advisable some how to are
interesting now that's an interesting
way to play I have knight c6 though just
technically motivated and then take the
five isn't this possible seems to be
I even if this should be fun maybe with
the temple Queen c3 Bishop before and
then take on d5 is even better yeah that
sets that's looking very nice for black
yeah t5 just faults I think you can go
to e3 but I just take the file with no
particular compensation night b4 is also
difficult maybe that's even stronger but
ok taking cannot be bad I'm threatening
default so so we does not have time for
any fancy moves now I probably can just
recapture CD 525 and then Bishop c5 is
coming with the tempo unless it's
playing that ok but anyway of rook d8 on
how do i would like to and I canceling
shortest if is difficult we should see
for coming maybe maybe Queen D for his
right just getting getting Queens off
for work yet yeah it all it's all good
in a way but how to determine the the
maximum here but this looks ok yeah
queen d force my intention
okay I can take between now I wonder
ever should to hangs it's not exactly
great for his coordination if I do them
do you take and you cannot castle and a
threat you look T to huh probably at
least in some cases if he plays 93 for
example then look T 2 wins outright yeah
here also is Bishop b4 was my idea or
just queen bee 60 there's nothing really
to be set against this
yeah well just be sure before that stuff
this is ok I cannot cancel them
yeah probably just taking rookie one
Bishop tea for you probably will yeah we
recapture like this yeah and now how do
i how do i play this without allowing
any any big account to play Queen d2
maybe Quincy five hmm queen bee six
maybe I'm getting getting the Queen's
off 122 Quincy five the texts the the
bishop okay let's let's get the Queen's
off that's it's probably not ideal but I
want to make sure that nothing terrible
is happening to my king okay rook t2 was
my original thought or maybe maybe do it
like that allowing f5 so that I keep the
F poor and I can return this this p6 but
i'll keep the f porn allowing f65 okay
um should be five okay let's do this
first um yeah I still have a protected
pass on time morning look T to killing
Bishop I don't have a good square now
ready okay maybe baby to be five
yeah it was clearly not the best way to
punish white quite clearly not okay give
a number of checks now check check
he needs to be very passive now on yeah
I'll do this and here i can take a tool
can I take a tune or g2 let's let's keep
this no don't have a trick keeping in
keeping age seven protected I hope this
is good g2 is still hanging this is what
I'm I'm having hopes I'm setting my hope
song chang check race going to e6 moon
that's not good check oh no I really
have lost the thread here check ha ha
check check check white workers I tried
to offer a draw but I went on time with
90 point 95 seconds wait what did I do
wrong I mean from this completely
winning position so what did I do wrong
let me let me check this Queen d2 was
pretty good and then we should be form
but okay this cannot really be be the
problem Queen a3 of course Queen a 30
tween a3 is much stronger of course with
Bishop c5 coming then I I didn't see the
as it simply didn't see Queen a three
and then I get to see Five controlling
controlling all the important squares
this isn't so clearly it is not i mean i
cannot castle and 93 years in there
this was probably relatively speaking
the best what I did just keeping keeping
everything china this still pin still an
advantage for black but obviously not
easy to play Bishop a6 are stronger yeah
I don't I didn't see that Bishop e7
Bishop protects b7 I only saw that idea
to protection on on g7 yet here we were
just we were just both playing check
playing random moves I couldn't really
calculate anything check check ya know
now why does ahead but Jackie we both
did anytime I need to play Queen a three
yeah the opening or ever was a big
success again it's not clear to me how
wide is untangling here maybe I've
formed around here I have a really nice
position I mean knight c6 is a very very
serious threat here and it's hard to
hard to find a computer as already
saying that black is winning him that's
remarkable yeah 96 is serious there is
some not much that I read what can do
against it the calm wants to play G for
which looks completely wacky no it's
just good probably okay thanks for
watching